hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Mary
Russell Mary Russell director of the
short film called card you can check out
the trailer for that she's the writer of
it - and I just found out on her
Facebook page
she's got half naked photos so check
that out - what we're gonna do is check
out a video called five terrifying
real-life scenarios in movies
brought to you by Screen Rant let's do
this
or will these terrorized viewers with
tales of ghosts monsters and sometimes a
goblin or two but films don't
necessarily have to have one of those
elements in order to be scary throughout
history there have been plenty of
examples of filmmakers using real-life
fears to create premises in a movie that
are as frightening as your average
paranormal pest yeah you're a
screenwriter five terrifying real-life
scenarios movies Apollo 13
many kids streak all becoming an
astronaut one day but one viewing of
Apollo 13 might be all it takes to turn
those dreams into nightmares the film is
based on the true story of NASA's Apollo
13 mission it depicts the darker side of
the profession as three astronauts are
left floating in space and a broken
module
among the many obstacles they face are
freezing temperatures rising carbon
dioxide levels and malfunctioning
systems all of which could prove fatal
even though NASA is aware of this
situation that doesn't exactly make it
bearable if the worst could happen at
any given moment
Jim Lovell and his crew displayed true
bravery and courage by never folding
under the an immense pressure and
finding a way to return home safely
meanwhile we were happy to be on solid
ground
127 oh yeah before setting off on a
weekend excursion to the mountain Aron
Ralston doesn't bother to tell anyone
where he's heading that absent judgment
comes back never saw this film Ralston
has an accident and gets his arm trapped
under a local community by date he's the
director Danny Boyle shot selection is
unnerving because it illustrates wrong
passengers a slow march seemingly to his
death the video messages he records for
his loved ones are especially bet
wrenching I love you guys James and the
infamous cutting off the arms yeah
Merson seemed to watch ah you know this
movie may encourage you to become a
whole body and who could blame you
hastily we've all fantasized about
having Tommy survive but Chuck Noland
would recommend you rethink time for
surviving a plane crash which is scary
enough he spends four years on an
isolated piece of land with almost no
hope of reaching the outside world
despite the company of his faithful
companion Wilson Chuck is very much
alone a concept that taps into one of
our basic emotional fears
it deals with scorching heat fierce
rainstorms and unbearable hunger
he's even driven to attempt suicide as
fascinating as it is to watch Tom Hanks
work his magic there's no denying that
this is one horrifying experience for
anyone to consider the great forget the
marketing lie that I like does Neeson vs
wolves the gray is still a solid work of
horror first and foremost it's a man
versus nature piece since the greatest
enemy art way and his crew must face our
freezing temperatures and the harsh
Alaskan wilderness that's not to say
that territorial wolves are easy to deal
with they presented their own challenges
of the group struggle to survive trying
to hunt them down whenever they got a
chance director Joe Carnahan gave
audiences some really tense and
nail-biting sequences that Illustrated
the relentlessness of the environment
and how there was so little humans could
through the games with prisoners yeah
the childish little Missy
so prisoners is nightmare fuel for
anyone with a kit the film is so
effective because even those without any
offspring can instantly feel sympathetic
back Harry as carried over hugh jackman
portrayed a man consumed by helplessness
in greek and everyday she's wondering
why I'm not there do you understand me
not you he's driven to the point of
insanity struggling to find information
about where his daughter went off to for
anyone trying to see themselves in the
protagonist prisoners asks a horrifying
version of the question what would you
do and forces us to consider some
shocking answers those are our picks for
five terrifying real-life scenarios and
movies are there any weakness which non
horror movies keep you up late at night
sound off in the comments below and be
sure to subscribe to our channel for
more videos like this one
miss gravity wasn't on there
said Apollo 13 you know well gravity
yeah I mean I felt gravity had mixed
feelings about yeah I mean in terms of a
movie itself I really liked gravity but
I really loved the visuals of gravity I
think the narrative felt a little
repetitive to me I don't know much about
space and scientist
oh [ __ ] but I thought gravity got to
fear me a little bit more yeah yeah 13
did but Apollo 13 still it's a great
example of a real life scenario 127
hours I think I think a lot of these
real-life scenario films deal with the
theme of survival
yeah what do you do willing to do to
survive how are you you know are you
willing to are you gonna give up or you
know it's like like Tom Hanks in
castaway is he gonna kill himself in 127
hours it's like a lot of people wouldn't
feel like they could get to the point
where they could take out a [ __ ]
knife and just cut off their arm but
it's like if you really want to survive
you're gonna [ __ ] do it yeah and like
you think you couldn't but you do and
that's what's interesting about these
scenarios yeah 127 hours you have that
freaking out no that was uh not a
pleasant scene it's kind of a boring
movie for me to be honest money I mean
it probably that that's what I think cuz
like it's a one person one man yeah
under yeah yeah so I think it'd kind of
be a flat movie where there wouldn't be
like a contrasting character it's like a
character exploration of this time he's
in the mind and I get what it's going
for I was just a little bored until he
cut off his honor I mean I only like
James Franco when he was young he saw
this you know I'm surprised wasn't on
there cuz this was a true story Titanic
Titanic yeah being on their way really
saying Oh God
I was pissed that that she let everyone
pissed off about it yeah they could have
switched turns he could have like been
urinated on to keep them warmer or
something he could have urinated
he could have iourney turn on himself it
hasn't done that hasn't done that to
survive even in situations where it
won't help I'll do it in case it's like
when you when you get stung by a
jellyfish yeah it's just a pain on
yourself
yeah or oh my god I'm caught on fire
that simply you can I mean the the penis
goes in many directions so you can
direct it thank you what kind of penis
are you what the [ __ ] the penis goes in
many directions isn't it like a hose I
mean I yes but I'm not a fan of like
pointing my dick if you were to save
someone oh I had to say yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah with the pee Oh totally I
get what you're saying yeah no I would
know wouldn't use my hose yeah it was
castaway
you know people always ask that question
if you were stuck on an island what
would you bring into the I think growing
up we get that question so we do
sometimes fantasize of what if I was
alone on an island and stuff and that
movie do three wishes yeah well I love
about this video is you know I got this
question recently why do you like horror
movies I mean they're just darted and
it's not good for your mind like [ __ ]
like that right my answer was my answer
was almost every movie that's really
good has an element of horror there's
always an element of fear you have to
feel on edge you have to you have to
feel a fear of something you know
usually for a film to work there has to
be some type of fear and all horror does
is capitalise on that emotion of fear I
actually really enjoyed a lot of very
5050 with audiences but I heard yeah not
bad I mean I was fully entertained
prisoners I know you haven't seen I
haven't seen that was one of my favorite
movies that year and yeah I could
totally see how I mean I can only
imagine what it's like for someone's
child to I can understand if like I have
a kid one day and I don't really like
him and then I want to get rid of it
bad maze yeah bye-bye pirate kidnapper
be gone
welcome to Mexico when you actually love
the kid and they are abducted that must
be painful
just seeing the trailer I were seeing
like clips of the video I feel kind of
like I'm very interested in seeing this
film so you might even watch it tonight
buried I think could have been on buried
yeah yeah that movie what that's a
really cool movie yes I've never seen it
it's like 80 minutes long but it's it's
just him in the coffin yeah with a cell
phone yet I was pulled in the entire
time really is shot really well really
clever it manages to be very artistic
and stylistic in a coffin it's
terrifying like you really does give you
that feeling of being buried in a coffin
you see Kill Bill Vol - yes remember
when she's buried in the coffin yes yeah
like just yeah and then before that
though you hear the dirt falling on the
coffin like that's a scenario that's
like oh no oh God I mean it's unreal yes
uhm but there were real-life situations
in that film yeah that I can imagine
like waking up in in the hospital bed oh
yeah being raped that's one of my fears
that's one of my fears like being in the
hospital like after being asleep like
getting a surgery done and then like and
then waking up and having no idea what
just happened to you and your being in a
coma that's it's freaky that's what you
fear yeah I think that's one of my fears
what a specific fear it's a very
specific fear everyone's like snakes
clowns
I know but benign is having to get
surgery in the hospital and then going
to sleep for several days and not know
any what happened yeah I see how that's
scary but yeah it is scary you guys
would be to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out the trailer for Mary's short
film called carved fun greenhouse kind
of flick check it out it's gonna be
premiering soon we might be doing a
short film together for this channel so
if you look out front of that and you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter or vine periscope
she has a Facebook page too here's a
picture
like our page this one's for a unique
film hi I'm Ryan left and I'm Mary
Russell ha he really wanted me to say hi
I'm Ryan left and sit on the other side
of the couch I know but it's like the
screens left oh yeah I know it's neat
it's really sad what he was requesting
as if it's a person again as if it's
supposed to be entertaining for everyone
really I don't really think it's that I
feel like I just did that for him the
simple thing is that way keeps asking me
and I'm like dude no one's really gonna
laugh but you laugh yeah because I mean
what a charming man yeah really unique
unique film you yeah you're clearly
unique with their jokes yeah no one's
ever said Ryan left or Ryan wrong I'm
kind of the camera just [ __ ] cut em
cut into camp